all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with invincible
yes we are now this is one of those
stories where there's not really a
cohesive plot thread that runs through
the whole thing
instead it's just a series of things
that are kind of going on and kirkman
does that occasionally
right like there's usually a singular
plot threat in every single story and
that's usually what we focus on but
occasionally you get one of these where
it's just a bunch of things happening
at the same time one of the things that
we're going to deal with here what we're
going to focus on here
is basically what happened to omniman
after the events of earth and everything
that went on with the other planet when
he was captured by the vulture mites
we know that he's awaiting execution and
that's one of the things that we learned
is that whenever viltrumites basically
deviate from their role or they kind of
abandon quote unquote the charter of the
villager might race that they're
basically executed right which is kind
of a weird thing given the little bit of
information that we'll get here in a
little bit but essentially he's just
waiting on that
now of course we also had alan the alien
who of course you guys know has
telepathy who also got himself captured
so he could come across omniman because
word had reached his ears by way of his
conversations with mark and then a few
other people that basically omniman had
defected from the the charter of the
vulture minds basically indicating he
could be an ally for the coalition of
planets the coalition of worlds
i've heard you guys we you know kind of
run it off interchangeably honestly it
is i'm sure some super hardcore people
will be like
actually it's the coalition of planets
and it's like but who really cares
though so here's the thing
so what ends up happening is a kind of
conversation a really a series of
conversations
take place between allen and nolan and
this is an important thing
because the reality is all they have is
each other for reasons that aren't
really made relevant or made apparent to
alan uh
ultimately the vulture mites haven't
quite shown up yet instead one of the
things that goes on this is one of the
things that we've kind of talked about
before
is that the vulture might actually
conscript other races that they've
conquered to kind of work alongside with
them sort of beefing up their numbers so
they're really more like field troops
and different things like that and in
this
instance these guys have tried to like
kill alan and it doesn't work right he's
just too durable for the weapons they
have and so
ultimately it's just one of these things
where it's just kind of biting time and
in the conversations that alan and nolan
have
they've actually kind of developed
friendships for each other right they're
kind of talking about loves they've lost
relationships they've been in making
sacrifices for the greater good
all that kind of stuff and ultimately a
bond forms here a bond that forms in the
sense that it's kind of like hey like
we're
brothers in arms in a lot of different
ways we've both sacrificed we've both
lost we've both gained and so finding
that common ground leads to what is
basically a friendship form between the
two of them which is kind of wild
because before they really knew who the
other was they were enemies
they were basically fighting each other
and so at the end of it all you have the
vulture mites who finally show up on the
scene and the intention is to basically
take out nolan the funny thing is that
in that process while nolan was awaiting
his execution and so was alan alien they
had basically formed a plan
and in doing so allen breaks himself out
of jail and during that time
battlebeast arrives as well and so
that's kind of a big thing because a lot
of you guys know battle beats is a horse
right this guy
is an absolute monster literally and
figuratively
but battle beast also lives for the for
the hunt he lives for the conflict right
he
basically looks to better himself
through battle and through war
and so fighting alongside alan the alien
they ultimately arrive to where nolan is
going to be executed and then
essentially save him and that's one of
the things when like when he's like okay
so like it's filter mites right and and
battle beast
realizes that it's a filter might his
desire is to face him in battle right
because the vulture minds are like the
most feared race across the universe and
by defeating one would kind of solidify
his position as being the foremost and
really one of the most formidable beings
in
all of creation the problem is there's
not really a lot of time for that i mean
there is
they can kind of defeat these guys but
their biggest concern is that more
more vulture mites are going to be
coming and so basically they kind of
just jettisoned all these
these you know guys who are working for
the vulture might just send them flying
out into space
they basically defeat the two vulture
mites that are here and then allen kind
of starts to go into a panic and saying
like we have to find
you know i have to find my my scanner it
has all the information i've gained all
that kind of stuff and we have to do
that before the vulture might get here
and the response of nolan is they're not
coming there are no more filter mics
that are going to be coming and when the
question is asked why
nolan basically reveals the best kept
secret among the vulture might race
which is
while they are feared across the
universe as this kind of nigh
unstoppable race less than 50 of them
left there's hardly any pure-blooded
vulture mites left now that's something
important to keep in mind there's less
than
50 pure blood velcro mites there are
like filter mite breeds right half
breeds where it's like velcro mites who
procreated with a different member of a
different race
but ultimately in terms of the pure
blood velcro mites like nolan there's
there's less than 50 and that's the
reason why they don't necessarily
come flying in with absolute force
because they don't really want to risk
their number
right they don't really want to risk the
possibility of of losing
any more of those 50 than they possibly
have to and so ultimately what you end
up getting here
is kind of switching back to earth you
have basically mark and adam eve who are
together and they're basically banging
and his younger brother walks in on him
and of course mark takes off and
basically does the heroic thing or at
least responds to a call that he got
from amber
now when he gets there this is one of
those crazy things when he gets there
amber is kind of like okay well i mean
here's the thing right like the past few
weeks have been really really hard like
my dad died and i've been talking to
gary and i know it's a little awkward
having this conversation with you
instead of calling gary and then she
basically reveals and
it's it's kind of a weird thing she
basically reveals it like gary's been
beating her
right gary's been beating on her and
it's one of these things where gary came
off as a great guy so much so that she
actually dumped mark
for gary and so this kind of led to a
crazy thing because
like mark immediately freaks out now
mark's not gonna get back together with
amber right it's just one of those
things where it's like i'm with adam eve
now but
at the end of the day she is a friend
and so mark basically responds
by going and finding gary and he kind of
helps gary come to an understanding of
his place in the bigger picture by kind
of saying hey look man i know you like
putting your hands on girls so let me
put my hands on you
and we'll see how much you enjoy that
right and that's one of those crazy
things because he basically tells her if
you ever hit her again
i'm gonna come back i'm gonna find you
and i'm going to kill you it's kind of a
weird thing because as soon as mark gets
back to amber
and starts talking to her one of the
things that she'd done initially was
make excuses for gary well it was just a
one time thing
he was just really upset and that's a
lot of the things that you see when it
comes to people who have been through
abusive situations like that is they
often times
internalize why they were abused in the
first place well it was my fault if i
hadn't done that he wouldn't have hit me
if i hadn't done that
she wouldn't have attacked me because
guys get abused by women too even though
we don't like to talk about that so it's
one of these things when mark gets back
there and mark says
okay are you sure you want to stay with
this guy her response is well i mean
we've kind of been through a lot there
was
there was a lot of craziness that was
happening but like don't worry about me
mark everything is going to be fun right
famous last words but ever like
everything is going to be fine
you know everything's going to be cool
and mark ultimately leaves her and it's
kind of okay like this is what you want
this is what i will give you and so what
he ends up doing is of course traveling
back to adam eve and saying hey look
here's what was going on with amber that
gary was beating her so i beat the hell
out of gary and
i told him i'd kill him if he ever did
it again and then it's it's kind of
kind of interesting because he thought
she was gonna take it the wrong way
ultimately she doesn't right and she's
just kind of like i mean you know like i
totally understand where you're coming
from
i mean the guy was beating up a friend
of mine why would i be upset about you
going and tracking down the guy and
beating the crap out of him
following that mark realizes that he's
basically being spied on now as the
reader we know who it
is who's spying on him it's not cecil
but we know who it actually is that's
doing this
but mark believes that it is cecil and
so he ultimately ends up you know
traveling to cecil tracking him down
interrogating him a little bit ceaseless
kind of look man we're not the ones
spying on you but i do need your help
with something you know now of course
mark
is kind of like i mean look man like i'm
not looking to help you dude like i
don't trust you at all and that kind of
makes sense right i mean that's the
thing that we talked about in the last
video that cecil
kind of came off as this guy who was
like hey man i'm looking out for you
your dad did some bad stuff but your
family's gonna be taken care of you know
not necessarily like a father figure but
like an
uncle you know who was a little bit sus
like that was kind of the thing about
about uh cecil you know like you knew
there was something a little off about
him but you didn't really think it was
anything severe and then
in the the conflict that he had with
mark it was oh no man like we've
definitely got you under lock and key
like we're monitoring you we're keeping
an eye on your family we don't really
trust you i'm just kind of putting off
this air so you'll continue to work with
us by all standards of measurement he
destroyed any measure of trust that
existed between himself and mark but as
far as cecil went it was that's the
price i'm willing to pay to basically
keep the world safe from people like
your father potentially people like you
or anybody else out there who could be a
credible threat and so what you end up
doing is basically switching over to
gary hampton now gary hampton is a bit
of a weird situation of course you
switch over to him because that's the
person that cecil basically needs help
with
gary has a bit of a lengthy history here
and that's one that we could potentially
talk about if you guys are interested in
it but all that really matters in this
whole thing
is that yuri was at one point a
billionaire ultimately he ended up being
transformed into a werewolf he kind of
goes by the name of wolfman he was a
hero for a little while but for the most
part
knowledge or at least public knowledge
of gary hampton the billionaire being
secretly a werewolf was kind of kept
hidden right nobody really knew that
eventually it became public knowledge
when his daughter walked in on him with
a dead body of his wife and the
presumption was
he killed his wife now there was a lot
of history going on there the fact that
he had kind of dove into his work before
he became a werewolf the fact that he
kind of drove his wife away by somebody
just ignoring her for the most part she
went to the arms of another man
anybody who understood the inner
workings of their family and the
struggles that they'd gone through the
fact that he was under an embezzlement
investigation the fact that you know
he'd essentially lost everything while
the government sees his accounts and
froze everything
there's every reason to believe that
gary did actually kill his wife
right and so that's why the response of
cecil in them is that guy's definitely
guilty the other thing is
there was a bit of a backstory with a
guy by the name of zechariah who you
immediately knew with sus
ended up being a bad guy and then
ultimately you ended up having gary
seeking out what's called the elder
basically this guy who's kind of like
the elder
werewolf for lack of a better word and
kind of teaches gary the ropes and how
everything works kind of enhances
abilities expand on them and so on and
so forth again we can actually focus on
that if you guys care i don't imagine a
whole lot of you guys do a lot of you
guys are probably really more interested
in what's going on with like omniman and
all that kind of stuff honestly because
it's the coolest thing
but the elder is not really teaching
gary to be a villain that's the
important thing he's actually teaching
him to be a hero he's like you are going
to go through a series
of trials and one of the first trials
you're going to go through is basically
protecting the innocent right like
keeping innocent people safe from what
is essentially a credible threat and
that's when you basically have giant
who's returned now
giant is a character that we haven't
really talked about before the long and
short of it is that he was a kid who was
yanked into a different dimension and
then came back in his current form
and just much like a kid kind of goes on
these rampages not fully understanding
what he's capable of he was eventually
put in a kind of containment system and
then
managed to escape hence where he's at
right now and cecil and then were just
trying to find a way to recontain him
again he was certainly able to give
mark a run for his money right like he
was able to to beat the crap out of mark
basically
and that's why mark is none too keen on
tracking this kid back down again
but he kind of treats him like a kid
right like authority right like a strong
voice
firm hand that's the kind of thing that
a lot of kids need and that's what he
tells him right mark basically knocks
this kid down
quite readily and then it's just like
stay here right if you cut if you if you
keep on messing around like i'm gonna
beat the crap out of you i don't want to
do not get up right like i don't want to
hurt you anymore so
ultimately the kid just sits there until
the authorities arrive but this was the
mission that gary hampton himself had
actually been sent on which was
basically protecting innocent people
from this this giant now the reality is
gary probably would not have been able
to do it on his own and i don't think he
was really
expected to i think it was really more a
test of courage and conviction
is he willing to put his life on the
line to save innocent people and so of
course because of the fact that cecil
and them are looking for him and the
belief out there is that he killed his
wife
while he and mark kind of talk a little
bit about how they teamed up and
he basically helped mark with uh with
seismic a little while back mark's like
but i mean i gotta i still gotta take
you in
dude bolts like he immediately he
immediately takes off like
literally like mark's like i gotta take
you in and he just bam he just takes off
he's like oh no you're not either
he literally tries to run but the funny
thing is that mark's operating on the
information given to him by cecil
and then once gary's able to make his
case mark realizes there's something
else going on here right gary's like
look man
i didn't kill my wife i simply walked in
on her i found her dead
and then my daughter saw me with the
body and then that's what everybody's
operating on right basically
circumstantial evidence now the argument
that cecil initially made was look we
just want to bring him in so we can
interrogate him question him stuff like
that but we know that whatever cecil
says
believe the opposite right so there's no
intention of like bringing him in
questioning him getting to the bottom of
the case and then freeing him if
it's actually untrue cecil's not looking
to work as this guy's defense lawyer
he's in the business of like contain and
control
and that's exactly what would happen
here that maybe he would get to talk to
his lawyer
if cecil feels like letting him or most
likely cecil would use him for his own
ends right to create his own kind of
suicide squad thing which is
basically what the guardians of the
globe are without the bombs in their
heads right that's essentially what
they've kind of been turned into
and so he really kind of pleads the case
and tells him everything that's going on
he was like like right now like this guy
that i was working with like he's a
mentor right he's training me guiding me
teaching me how to use my powers
and he says i thought i had that at a
previous point in time and it turned out
i was wrong i thought i had a mentor but
he was hiding things right like
that guy killed my wife like he's the
one who did it right that guy's zach
zechariah like he's the one who killed
my wife and i walked in on him doing it
and then in turn it was my daughter who
walked in
with me at the body believing that i was
the one that did it like it's literally
just like a framing thing i mean he
didn't intentionally frame me but that's
how it all just kind of turned out that
i'm not actually the bad guy here but
ultimately because of the emotion that
he puts forward because of how he looks
right just the overall tone that he
gives this is way beyond
some kind of sociopath who's
manipulating mark into believing that
he's telling the truth
instead it's basically one of these
things where it's like this guy's
actually telling the truth and zechariah
is out there and he wants to get revenge
on this guy like he wants to kill the
guy who killed his wife and then after
that
you know who knows maybe go back to
being a hero but it's a very
understandable motivation
it's a very graspable motivation and so
ultimately mark's like
i believe you right like i'm just going
to take you into cecil we'll get
everything cleared up and then cecil's
guaranteed to let you go right it kind
of astounds me even at this point
mark is this naive right they were just
gonna be like i don't know what happened
cecil he got away man
like it's werewolf stuff man he just he
it was just some cloud and then he used
some powers and disappeared
i don't know what to tell you but of
course he ends up bringing him in right
and that's kind of the funny thing is as
soon as he gets in here the most logical
situation happens when it's basically
like let this guy make his case right
let gary hampton make his case
let him talk and at the end of the day
cecil's like there's nothing i can do
here man
like there's there's nothing i can do
here right i mean you know it's just you
know
it's out of my hands right now the
reality is there's a lot cecil could do
here but cecil doesn't want to do
anything because cecil has a particular
goal he's looking to achieve with with
wolfman which is he wants to use him for
his own ants
and so ultimately because of the fact
they're meeting in the white room that
all these little you know robot zombie
guys come running right the the rihanna
man come running up on them all and
we've seen this play out before
right this is one of those instances
where it's kind of like okay like
kirkman's kind of repeating himself a
little bit and that doesn't happen a
whole lot but it kind of does sometimes
and of course
these rihanna man are dead are dealt
with quite readily but the problem is
they ultimately need an out right they
need a way out because they're just
hopelessly outnumbered and while the
brianna men don't necessarily exhaust
mark and wolfman do right they can get
tired now
if this was omni man no it wouldn't be a
contest right he would
you would sweep through them quick fast
and in a hurry he kind of swathed
through all of a quick fast in a hurry
and like that would be it but
mark is not omni man so they basically
end up finding themselves out they
literally break out of the out of the
pentagon
building and then while they are kind of
tracked down a little bit they're
ultimately located by the guardians of
the globe right so literally
mark invincible versus the guardians of
the globe and when i say versus
i say that very loosely because this
fight is no fight at all the reality is
the fight between
immortal and mark has been coming for
quite some time right i mean look this
fight's been coming on for a while
because they've both got frustrations to
work out right like
immortal doesn't like mark he thinks
he's too reckless he thinks he's too
young to lead anything
mark doesn't like immortal because the
guy's a dick right so like it's one of
these things where like they've been
looking to conflict with each other for
quite some time and so it's like mark
literally tells him he's like look guys
i don't want to hurt you like i'm tired
of holding back against you guys
and that's the reality is mark's been
holding back against them and it's one
of those things where like no
one really understood how how much he
was holding back right it's almost like
when dr octopus became superior
spider-man right and like
knocked the jaw off the scorpion and
then came to the realization holy cow
peter parker's been pulling his punches
all this time that's basically what's
going on here
right like mark's never really gone
balls to the wall
full bore on these guys and he does
right he snatches up the immortal with
an instant and just like
pummels everybody else using the body of
the immortal and then throws the
immortal out into the air right that's
it this fight lasts
seconds but i mean it's not a lengthy
battle and then immediately grabs
wolfman and just says like we're out of
here right and they basically just take
off now he drops him drops him back off
where where the mentor has or at least
takes him to his family for a little bit
hey y'all kind of talk to the family
butler for a minute not a whole lot
going on here it's just one of these
things where it's kind of this this
recognition by a third party that they
know gary didn't do it and so it's kind
of verifying that gary's actually
telling the truth both for mark and for
us as the reader
as well as giving a little bit of
follow-up to some of the previous plot
threats that we've seen over the course
of the invincible story but ultimately
it's kind of like
like i'm going to find zechariah right
like that's my thing like i'm going to
take this guy out
i'm going to destroy this guy the other
part of this and this is something that
that
is a little frustrating here is that the
daughter of gary
is showing a lot of anger and a lot of
rage and she's and and
ultimately like she's being given a lot
of space but at the same time
what she needs is somebody to give her a
more guiding hand but she needs her
father but the biggest fear
is because of all this anger and because
of all this rage that she could go on
becoming something terrible the other
part of that is
because she was accosted because she was
bitten by what was initially a vampire
as opposed to as opposed to wolf man who
is a werewolf the concern is she's gonna
become a vampire so then you basically
have her
as a villain right so again kind of an
interesting little little thread here
interesting little plot thread but
ultimately uh gary's kind of dropped
back off in the woods by by mark they
sort of call it a day they're basically
friends you know allies at this point
and this is one of those instances when
kirkman's basically building up the
roster
for the purpose of giving us allies for
a mark much later on down the road
who could all basically help him the
other part of this is that you actually
end up switching over to a couple
different things the first is monster
girl
robot finished working on the ability to
keep her from getting younger and
because of the fact that every time she
turns into her monster and she goes back
into her human form
she ages a little bit less this is all
basically predicated on the idea that
much like bruce banner turning into the
incredible hulk
unlike that circumstance when banner
goes back to his normal self when she
does it basically puts herself together
in the wrong order which makes her
younger right that's why she keeps
getting younger and so looking at it
from a scientific standpoint the only
real answer here
is not that robot can age her back up to
where she's supposed to be
that seems to be impossible instead he
can keep her from getting younger and so
all this really means is whenever
she's wearing this belt or as she always
wears this belt she turns into her
monster then she goes back to her
younger self she stays that same age she
doesn't actually get younger anymore now
seemingly this almost kind of puts off
an error of potential immortality but
it's one of those things that we'll kind
of have to look at much later on down
the line the other part of that is that
with
mark basically being monitored the
person who's watching him is angstrom
levy which again we've known for quite
some time
what we didn't know he was doing was
basically operating behind the scenes
that what he's actually done
is gone to alternate realities and
grabbed different alternate reality
versions of mark that basically there's
some where he became like a like
essentially a velcro mic that conquered
the earth he followed in his father's
footsteps but like all these different
iterations of his character and in
effect mark is going to have to
have to fight an army of alternate
reality versions of himself but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching
i will catch you all later peace